[Musique]
salut à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
d'un sujet que les médias et les
politiques préfèrent taire au nom du
vivre ensemble
l'antisémitisme d'origine musulmane en
france quand on a des actes antisémites
préfère parler d'antisémitisme vague
comme s'ils étaient diffusées dans toute
la société
pourtant cet antisémitisme musulmans
délivrant parle des musulmans le dénonce
et quand on a des statistiques elles
sont très claires selon lagence
européenne pour les droits fondamentaux
les violences antisémites en france ou
dans les trois quarts des cas le fait de
musulmans et c'est manifestement de cet
antisémitisme la dont il est question
quand on parle de recrudescence de la
haine des juifs en france
je vous propose donc d'essayer de
comprendre la charge antisémites sont
potentiellement porteuses la culture
musulmane via un angle particulier la
vie du prophète
alors pourquoi cet axe est bien parce
que le prophète toute sa vie a été
confronté aux juifs
alors je ne dis pas que c'est la seule
explication possible mais la violence
des faits vous allez le voir permettent
elles seules d'expliquer l'antisémitisme
dans la culture musulmane
de plus le prophète n'est pas n'importe
qui c'est le plus un des hommes sa vie
et ses paroles fondatrice de l'islam et
c'est un exemple à suivre pour tous
musulmans le coran d'ailleurs reconnaît
cette exemplarité le récit que je vais
vous faire est réalisé à partir de
biographies traditionnelle du prophète
la syrah donc il existe plusieurs
versions celle que j'ai utilisées et
principalement celle de tabari parce que
c'est celle que j'ai trouvé complété par
un ouvrage moderne mahomet le lecteur
divin il y aura pas mal de citations du
coran et de la syrah dont une invite à
mettre pause pour les lire
tranquillement également comme il ya peu
des illustrations il aura pas mal de
montage un petit peu nawak
vous êtes prévenus et tout d'abord
commençons par un petit tour d'horizon
du contexte historique dans lequel a
vécu le prophète l'arabie du 7e siècle
après jésus-christ est composé d'une
myriade de tribus nomades et sédentaires
qui cohabitent plus ou moins bien
parfois au sein des mêmes villes et
oasis au niveau religieux le pays aussi
est très divers
vous avez des juifs des chrétiens des
animistes et des polythéistes avec des
cultes variés l'une des villes la mecque
est un centre religieux pour plusieurs
peuples polythéistes avec un temple
commun la kaaba où sont présentes de
nombreuses idoles un clan polythéistes
domine la ville le clan courrech dont
est issu mahomet mahomet navire 570
après jésus-christ est à 40 ans il
commence à voir la révélation et fonde
une nouvelle religion dans la continuité
du judaïsme et du christianisme
il commence à prêcher à la mecque mais a
peu de succès de plus cela crée des
tensions notamment au sein de son clan
puisque de fait il renie la culture
tribale
c'est dieu et ses codes traditionnels
mais il est protégé par son oncle ce qui
lui permet d'être en relative sécurité
à l'époque c'est le règne de la loi du
talion attaqué mahomet même malgré son
reniement des cultes ancestraux
déclenchera une vendetta mais suite au
décès de son protecteur sa présence est
de moins en moins tolérées à la mecque
et son salut va venir de l'extérieur de
l'oasis de yathrib diatribe qui
deviendra médine est une oasis à
quelques centaines de km de la mecque
elle abrite plusieurs zones de
peuplement sorte de village avec des
fortins il y a deux tribus arabes les
house et les rase rage ces derniers
étant les plus nombreux et trois tribus
juives les banou kay nou ka les banou
nadir et les banou corps et âmes à cette
époque yathrib est secoué par des
tensions inter tribal et social
probablement en partie à cause de
questions démographiques et les
habitants cherchent un moyen d'apaiser
la situation
certains rencontrent mom et à la mecque
lors d'un pèlerinage qui leur explique
l'islam ils sont intéressés et tout le
monde et gâteries ben y compris les
juifs se met à espérer que mahomet
puisse rétablir la concorde la situation
des hommes et à l'amex dégradant ses
disciples étant victime de brimades et
lui-même comment sont à craindre pour sa
vie décide de partir pour yathrib avec
une partie de ses fidèles
c'est l'hégire l'émigration qui marque
l'an 1 du calendrier musulman
il réussit à réunir tout le monde sous
son autorité et créer un texte d'accord
la constitution de médine ainsi au mais
créer une alliance tripartite entre les
en sarre qui sont les médinois
converties à l'islam
ses partisans mais quoi qu'on appelle
les émigrés et les juifs de yathrib mais
très vite les relations avec les tribus
juives vont se dégrader
d'abord une fois l'ordre réinstaller non
mais va essayer d'étendre sa religion se
situant dans la continuité du judaïsme
il va essayer de convertir les juifs
tout comme chez les chrétiens la
conversion des juifs devient une affaire
importante
il prit leur dieu et leur conversion
serait pour lui une forme de
reconnaissance
mais comme pour les chrétiens les juifs
refuse de se convertir à l'islam
pourtant le prophète mais les moyens
pour les séduire en adoptant nombre de
leurs pratiques religieuses comme par
exemple prier tourner vers jérusalem
mais non seulement les juifs ne veulent
pas se convertir mais en plus ils font
cause commune avec des convertis
médinois pas très fervent appelé
hypocrite qui se sont convertis surtout
pour retrouver l'unité de l'oasis et qui
à la longue trouve la présence du
prophète envahissante
parmi les raisons de ce désamour de
certains médinois on trouve l'arrivée
importante de musulmans mais quoi alors
que médine est une petite oasis qui ne
peut accueillir tout le monde
c'est d'ailleurs à cause de cette
précarité matérielle que le prophète
d'instaurer les attaques de caravanes
marchande notamment contre celle de sa
tribu les koresh le coran lui témoigne
de la tension qui émerge avec les juifs
médinois ils vont notamment être accusé
de ne pas reconnaître sciemment le
prophète qui les accusent de falsifier
les écritures qui de fait ne
correspondent pas à sa propre
interprétation très libre de l'histoire
juive mahomet va aussi détourné
l'héritage symbolique juifs nous pouvons
avoir leur légitimité par le ralliement
il va inventer une ascendance millions
les arabes au prophète juif par ismaël
un fils illégitime d'abraham
il va aussi réinterpréter l'existence de
la kaaba dorénavant considéré comme un
lieu de culte initialement monothéistes
construite par adam ce qui permet
d'affaiblir la portée symbolique de
jérusalem est va lui permettre de
réorienter la prière vers la mecque
grâce à ces réécritures le prophète n'a
plus besoin des juifs pour se
revendiquer de leur héritage
la réorientation de la prière va aussi
avoir des conséquences pratiques la
mecque devient la ville la plus sainte
devant jérusalem
or elle est aux mains des infidèles et
il faut la reconquérir à partir de 624
mahomet s'attelle à la tâche et lance le
jihad
l'arrivée de mahomet à médine avait
permis de faire l'unité politique autour
de lui mais l'arrivée massive de
mecquois et son projet qui est aussi
religieux et qui passe rend plus
maintenant par la guerre contribuer à
réactiver des tensions avec les juifs et
une partie des arabes de yathrib entre
624 et 627 marc mais va se débarrasser
des tribus juives des gâteries ben sans
que les sources historiques et
religieuses nous permettent clairement
de comprendre pourquoi la non conversion
a joué un rôle
les tensions théologiques sont vite
apparues entre le prophète et les juifs
la réorientation de la prière intervient
deux ans après son arrivée yathrib mais
mahomet craignait certainement aussi que
cette mésentente débouche sur une
alliance entre juifs et koresh ce qui
pose est d'autant plus ce problème
qu'ils possèdent et 60 des 70 fortin de
l'oasis
car les corrèges ne vont pas rester
inactif face aux pillages deux caravanes
et vont organiser des expéditions
militaires en faisant appel à des tribus
alliées cela donne lieu à la bataille de
bader qui remporte les musulmans mais
qui convient peut-être aussi mauvais
qu'il vaut mieux prévenir que guérir
les premiers à subir son courroux sont
les banking books a qui sont la plus
faible des trois tribus juives
ce sont des artisans pas des guerriers
une étincelle anecdotique sert alors de
prétexte d'une musulmane ayant été
harcelés par des membres des cailloux
cas mahomet fait le siège de leur
forteresse pendant quinze jours et les
juifs finissent par se rendre
mahomet ordonne d'exécuter les hommes et
de réduire les femmes et les enfants en
esclavage pratique courante à l'époque
mais un musulman ibn au bail
un des chefs de la tribu des house
alliés des juifs est aussi membre des
hypocrites intervient en leur faveur et
le prophète leur accorde la vie sauve
ils partent alors vers eibach une oasis
juive située à 150km de médine et les
musulmans obtiennent leurs biens à
l'occasion un nouveau versets du coran
est révélée portant sur la répartition
du butin à verser dans la révélation est
bien pratique
quelques temps plus tard gab'1 des chefs
de la tribu juive des banou nadir
déclamant public des verts en hommage
aux guerriers courrech mort lors d'une
bataille et se moque de mener ce qui
irrite ce dernier qui demande qu'on le
débarrasse des musulmans membres de la
tribu des house se propose d'effectuer
la besogne
une tante d'un traquenard et finissent
par lui tomber dessus ils le tuent à
coups de sabre et dans la bagarre l'un
des assassins rejoint coût d'un de ses
collègues et a le cuir chevelu en taille
et une fois le forfait accompli
ils vont annoncer à mahomet que le poète
est mort et le prophète souffle alors
sur la tête du blessé qui cicatrise
immédiatement suite à cela les musulmans
de la tribu rage rage voulant eux aussi
se faire mousser propose à mahomet
d'assassiner un chef de la tribu juive
de raï bar aboura fille nommée leur
donne alors carte blanche une équipe
réussit à s'introduire arribart et tu
avoueras fille dans sa chambre
dans leur fuite l'un des courageux
musulmans se casse la jambe et ils vont
ensuite annoncé leur succès à mahomet
qui au passage toucha jambes du blessé
qui guérit instantanément deux fois de
suite des musulmans assassinés de façon
peu glorieuse des juifs
se blesse au passage et sont soignés par
le prophète on a là une caution divine
de leur forfait le message est clair tué
un juif vous plairait à dieu
parallèlement les musulmans continuent
leur guerre économique contre les
mecquois et avoue soufiane le chef des
courrèges décide d'en finir avec mahomet
cela donne lieu à la bataille de woods
le père mahomet notamment à cause de la
défection du dubaï suite à cette défaite
le climat délétère à médine les
hypocrites complotent et essaie de
pousser les deux tribus juives restantes
à la révolte
non mais décide alors de régler son
compte à l'une des deux tribus et banoun
à dire qui par le jeu des alliances sont
liées à certains de ses ennemis
pris de panique les chefs de la tribu
organise un attentat contre le prophète
un homme est censé le tuer en lui jetant
une pierre sur la tête oui c'est de
l'attentât d'amateurs mais comme on dit
en harami faut pas se masquer mahomet
bien sûr en réchappe et fait ensuite le
siège des bâtiments des bananes à dire
qu'ils se rendent après 15 jours les
juifs sont finalement autorisé à partir
vers eibach comme la tribu précédente
en abandonnant tous leurs biens c'est
bien notamment des palmeraies vont
revenir aux émigrés les ans à eux n'ont
rien car il n'y a pas eu de combats ce
[ __ ] permet aux émigrés d'être enfin
indépendant économiquement et puis il ya
le cas de la troisième tribu des banu
qurayza dont le sort est réglé après la
bataille du fossé abou sofiane vient
alors attaqué yathrib mais mahomet a
fait creuser un fossé autour empêchant
les charges de cavalerie l'attaquent
tourner au siège et les corrèges
finissent par lever le camp au final la
bataille a fait moins de dix morts mais
elle celle l'avenir des banou corps et
âmes
ceux-ci s'étant alliés ou ayant envisagé
de s'allier au collège paul hors du
siège normal pas ce qui est arrivé aux
deux autres tribus mahomet saute sur
l'occasion pour s'en débarrasser il fait
le siège de leurs fortins pendant 25
jours et les banu qurayza finisse par
demander une négociation il accepte un
arbitrage avec sade comme arbitre étant
l'un des chefs de la tribu house leur
ancien allié
ils peuvent espérer un verdict clément
l'exil comme les autres tribus mais ça 2
propose tout autre chose les hommes
doivent être exécutés et les femmes et
les enfants vendus comme esclaves
c'est un soumis au jugement et craignant
pour leurs familles s'y refuse et
baïocco reza accepte le verdict c'est
ainsi que 600 à 800 hommes de la tribu y
compris de jeunes adolescents vont être
égorgés par les musulmans mahomet lui en
profite pour prendre une nouvelle espèce
sexuelle parmi les prises une dénommée
rihanna qui refusera toujours le mariage
et la conversion à l'islam
d'ailleurs tu es les hommes et réduire
les femmes et les enfants en esclavage y
compris sexuelle ça ne vous rappelle
rien et oui c'est ce que les islamistes
de dèche ont fait où il est dit ils ne
sont pas et cela s'inspirer de cette
pratique du prophète en 2011 une
candidate à la députation koweïtienne
avait proposé que lors des guerres qu'on
puisse utiliser les femmes non
musulmanes des véhicules comme esclaves
sexuelles oui les actes du prophète
vieux de 14 siècles servent encore
aujourd'hui d'exemple y compris parfois
pour cautionner les pires pratiques
d'ailleurs le coran aussi valide cette
pratique de l'esclavagé sexuel
c'en est donc fini des tribus juifs de
médine mais le prophète lui n'en a pas
fini avec les juifs et tourne son regard
gris bar l'oasis où ont trouvé refuge
les deux premières tribus expulsés de
yathrib pour des raisons peu claires il
décide de faire le siège de l'oasis
les habitants de rabat repoussé par les
juifs exilés de yathrib peut être tentés
de s'allier aux courrech ou bien oasis a
peut être servi d'exutoire à ce moment
là les musulmans avaient signé un pacte
avec les quraysh le pacte d'odaiba qui
permettait aux musulmans de faire le
pèlerinage vers la mecque mais qui privé
aussi les combattants des razia qui
allait avec la guerre ribard a donc
peut-être servi à faire une razzia
facile toujours est il que mahomet fait
donc le siège de rails par les juifs se
rendent et le prophète s'attribue la
propriété de l'oasis mme et permet aux
habitants de rester en échange de la
moitié des récoltes annuelles
l'histoire ne s'arrête pas là parmi les
juifs vivent avec bar se trouve aussi
des banou la direction et de médine l'un
de leurs chefs qui nanar est supposé
avoir caché un trésor refusant de
révéler où est enterré ce trésor mahomet
le fait torturer
mais étant proche de la mort et ne
disant toujours rien mahomet fait venir
un dénommé masque hama pour qu'il achève
en guise de vengeance
keenan a ayant tué son frère lors de la
bataille pour venger la mort d'un
agresseur lors d'un combat mahomet fait
donc achever un mourant et l'histoire ne
s'arrête toujours pas là après ribard
mahomet s'intéresse à
fait à une benne ou nadir réduite en
esclavage après la bataille et qui est
devenue la possession d'un musulman
safia n'est autre que la veuve de keenan
ah non mais pour l'obtenir l'échangent
contre deux autres esclaves torturé un
homme à mort et ensuite prendre sa femme
comme esclaves sexuels après d'avoir
échangé
c'est à ça qu'on reconnaît le prophète
est une religion de paix et d'amour et
si vous trouvez cette affaire sordide
est bien c'est que vous êtes un sale
islamophobe bref la bataille de khaybar
sur la dernière livrée contre des juifs
le petit village voisin de sa dague
préférant se rendre aux mêmes conditions
plutôt que de combattre mahomet se
concentrera ensuite sur la prise de la
mecque qu'il finira par conquérir en 630
il fait alors détruire les idoles de la
kaaba et meurt deux ans plus tard
sa mort peut elle aussi entrée dans le
chapitre des relations avec les juifs
selon une version de la syrah en effet
après la bataille de rues barrées la
reddition de fada qu une juive qui
vivait une balloune à dire en exil dont
le mari avait été tué tenta
d'empoisonner le prophète avec une
épaule de moutons le prophète craché le
morceau de viande mais ensuite il sera
néanmoins malades tous les ans à la date
anniversaire de cet événement et
affirmera que sa mort est bien lié à cet
empoisonnement à l'histoire avec un
grand h
il faut aussi ajouter quelques éléments
théologique car les juifs sont fortement
associées à la figure de lentilles
religion ainsi lors de la fin des temps
l'équivalent de l'antéchrist le d'hadjal
viendra accompagné d'une armée de 70
mille juifs iraniens de plus nommer
lui-même foyers potentiellement ce
d'hadjal naître parmi les juifs
ainsi il aurait un temps soupçonné un
jeune juif appelé ibn zyad car il avait
les caractéristiques physiques requises
il était borgne et avait les cheveux
très bouclés
il avait de plus la mauvaise habitude de
troller le prophète en se proclamant
lui-même prophète de l'islam
ce qui bien sûr n'a pas plu à mahomet
sachez le et prophètes sont rarement
réputés pour leur sens de l'humour ou
mahomet il a donc surveiller et un de
ses compagnons a même proposé de le tuer
par précaution ce à quoi le prophète
répondit que de toute façon s'il était
le d'hadjal la tentative était vaine
et si ce n'était pas lui alors il
tuerait un 1900 voilà donc pour ce qui
est des relations entre le prophète et
les juifs
ces événements qui remontent à 14 e
siècle sont aujourd'hui encore important
pour les musulmans
par exemple les événements de red baron
fait l'objet d'une adaptation en série
en 2013
l'histoire je cite met en avant l'
hostilité et la haine des juifs envers
autrui leur nature fourbe leurs
multiples trahisons
racisme infâme cette série est passé sur
plusieurs chaînes arabes dont l'algérie
3 une chaîne faisant 20 % de part
d'audience dans le pays est disponible
en france via satellite
la détestation des juifs de la part de
certains musulmans ne peut pas être
expliquée uniquement par le conflit
israélo palestinien comme l'islamisme il
ne peut pas être non plus expliqué par
le manque de culture religieuse tout
musulman qui voudra approfondir sa
connaissance de la religion tombera sur
les mêmes versés et les mêmes épisodes
sanglants que moi et pourrait y trouver
une justification à son désir de
violence et à son intolérance l'islam
par l'histoire guerrière de son prophète
porte en elle même potentiellement une
justification de la haine du nom
musulman et de la violence et les temps
de s'en rendre compte si on veut lutter
contre l'antisémitisme musulman et si
vous êtes toujours dubitatif
et bien je vous invite à lire le coran
et la syrah pour juger par vous même
vous verrez cette vidéo n'est pas
exhaustive quant à l'intolérance et
l'antisémitisme présent dans ses
ouvrages et si vous avez apprécié cette
vidéo qui est maintenant terminée et
bien je vous invite à la partager
moi je vous donne rendez-vous pour une
prochaine vidéo ici là je vous dis
portez vous bien et à la prochaine
[Musique]